it's been about three months since this
what I call my 829 dollar 10-minute
doctor's visit I told the initial part
of the story before and I've been
getting emails from people including
podiatrists saying David what ended up
happening with this so here's the back
story in early June I went to see a
podiatrist because I was having some
foot and knee pain and my regular doctor
suggested I go I did all the right
things I called my insurance I said his
podiatry covered they said yes it is I
said do I need a referral they said no
you don't do I need Pryor do I need
pre-authorization they said no you don't
just book it and go you'll pay your $40
copay or whatever it is for specialist
and you're gonna be good to go and I
went and the doctor said hey okay I
think the problem you're having is that
because of your flat arches it's
throwing your entire ankles and knees
out of alignment you should get some
ortho custom orthotic in soles which of
course they didn't make there nor are
they covered by insurance the orthotics
are 350 or 375 bucks here's a
prescription but a boom bada bing you're
out of here okay I pay my copay and then
a few weeks later I get a bill a bill
saying your visit with the specialist
which was 10 minute maybe it was 10
minutes it was 10 minutes with me
spending 3 minutes sitting there while
the podiatrist types up notes right that
was a four hundred and sixty or so
dollar visit you've paid your $40 copay
it's not covered so you owe the other
420 dollars or so and I called the
insurance and I want to tell a shorter
version of this since I've already told
this I call my insurance and they say
well podiatry is covered and you don't
need a referral and you don't need prior
authorization but your diagnosis was
pest Planum or as we would say in
english flat feet and that is not a
diagnosis that is covered to which I
said wait a second how I'm not a doctor
do you agree I'm not a doctor yes yes we
agree you're not a doctor how would I
know whether to expect a diagnosis which
would not be covered it doesn't really
seem to make any sense so in the end
what was patan
really going to happen is I was going to
owe for this ten minute visit which
results in me getting some orthotics 350
or 375 for the orthotics and for 40 or
so whatever for the specialist visit it
was going to be roughly eight hundred
and thirty dollars now I got a bunch of
emails from podiatrists saying David I I
deal with this with patients and it's
crazy that on the basis of a diagnosis
code you would either be covered or not
covered but here are a bunch of other
codes that this is not insurance fraud
but these are just other ways that you
can report that someone came in with a a
pain related to a foot condition and
here's how I would often code it so I
played the game now at a certain point I
mean listen the truth is if this ends up
costing me 829 I'm fortunate enough to
be in a situation where it's not going
to bankrupt me and I'm putting a lot of
time into this but I do want to see it
through just to see like how long will
it take to ultimately navigate this and
what will be the result so I got in
touch with the specialist they put me in
touch with some billing person who of
course should they even exist in a
system that makes sense is that even a
position that we should have inflating
the bureaucratic cost of these visits I
would say no they said we're going to
resubmit it I'm gonna talk to the doctor
when the doctor if the doctor agrees to
resubmit it in a different way we will
do that call us in a month I called in a
month and was told that that billing
person had left and not on good terms
therefore no one there knows what it is
that they were working on so we again
started from scratch and I am here to
report to you today that there has been
no progress whatsoever my the the
specialist has said we're not going to
start charging you late fees we
understand that we're in the process of
trying to work this out so you're not
going to OS late fees but it has finally
been resubmitted to my insurance with
some other diagnostic codes and I'm
waiting to hear back and it could be
several more weeks before they either
accept or deny the claim the consider
all of the people and for what was seven
minutes of clinical time in three
minutes of note-taking time
consider not only what I might end up
paying but the amount of hours that I've
put into this again partially for you to
have stuff to talk about on the show
because of the curiosity of the entire
thing but this has been hours of my time
add up all of the hours of everybody
else who's been involved there's people
at my insurance company that have to
process this claim two times multiple
people at the specialists office
including the podiatrist himself working
on resubmitting this I'm caught it's
insane the system that we have and in
the end I'm not really any closer to
avoiding an eight hundred and twenty
nine dollar ten minute doctor's visit
than I was when this all started now if
you're going to email me and say David
in my country custom orthotic in soles
are only a hundred bucks I already heard
from two dozen of you I understand that
trust me I get that even the price of
three hundred and fifty dollars is a
crazy price and people from Canada and
the UK saying I just got custom ones for
80 bucks a hundred bucks and the
insurance even covers it in some cases
don't even depress me further with those
stories I get that that piece is going
on but that's the latest and I will
certainly keep you abreast of any
developments there